this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by our good buddies at
Squarespace who wants you to know you
can turn your great idea into a reality
with Squarespace
Squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're showcasing your work or selling
products of any kind with beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything you can yes you can
easily make a beautiful website yourself
and if you do get stuck Squarespace is
24/7 award-winning customer support is
there to help so head to squarespace.com
slash Grace for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain welcome
to another episode of not too deep with
me your host grace and helping the first
it is as always a very exciting episode
here on not too deep I have my good
friend Brad Jenkins with me who is Brad
Jenkins you might ask thank you for
asking he is the more former associate
director of the Office of Public
Engagement at the White House under the
Obama administration okay I know that
sounds like a lot of words and I could
barely speak them eloquently enough and
articulate exactly what that is cuz it's
an extremely interesting political
office he's basically a creative curious
wonderful human being that is super
excited about you utilizing your voice
in interesting creative ways and also
making politics understandable and
fundamentally exciting for people my age
I consider myself like the dumb
generation not to categorize all of us
in that but I myself from very dumb but
curious and I'm so excited that he's
here one to talk about his experience in
the White House which is nuts and to to
explain like why it's so important for
us to use our voice as adults in the
world that have this wonderful one guys
trust me I speak better in this episode
than I do right now I'm just overwhelmed
with information I'm sure you are too
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
Brad Jenkins
oh I'm so excited red Jenkins is here
Chris Oberg okay I've been wanting to
figure out how to correctly form this
opening question to people and I think
you are the perfect guest for me to test
this on so I'm sorry this is a question
I hate answering so I'm gonna put you on
the spot but for people that have no
idea who you are how do you explain what
you do oh man
it's bad I mean I I don't think I would
do you service trying to explain what
you do or like what your current
occupation is so I you know kind of give
it a professional this is the question
my parents asked me like so I'm a
producer and I think most people don't
even know what that is so I help finance
projects and the work that I do at Funny
or Die is political comedy right so the
work that I do is I used to work in the
Obama White House to clarify this the
Obama White House because because when
you say you worked in the White House as
a new White House now and lots of people
are getting fired so you could say
worked in a pastor at any point now and
be associated with that and the mooch
buddy cop comedy you don't so yeah so I
work at Funny or Die we have a whole
team that does partner productions which
is a fancy term for add campaign so you
do a lot of this branded entertainment
work so we work with corporations
studios movies music the work that I do
is for political campaigns so
organizations institutions foundations
candidates come to Funny or Die and they
asked for our help in reaching young
people which is very very hard for
political campaigns to do hard and
completely necessary and important
completely necessary and important yeah
so we've done I've been at Funny or Die
now for almost I guess three and a half
years we've done like 40 campaigns
is incredible it's very fun I met you
four plus years ago and I got a blind
invite to the White House with my good
friend mamrie Hart and it was so
overwhelming and so cool and we were so
not prepared because we had done the
show in DC with Hannah and we were so
hung over going to the White House where
we were literally like I have to wake up
we have to go we have to iron our
clothes we had to find something that is
decent to wear and we went and we were
just literally in this like foggy
hungover state being like well how are
we allowed in here and then we were
bowling all of a sudden and then we were
sitting in Michelle Obama's office and
then all the lights went off at one
point and we thought we were under
attack and it was just that the the
lights are on a monitor system and they
turned off because no one had moved in a
certain amount of time and then we had
her apples and we took apples from her
office had apples it was a whole thing
but so you I have so many questions so
part of me of my brain is like firing on
all cylinders right now you how did you
get started working with the Obama
administration I mean I know you you I
read a little bit in the book which is
like so exciting and I have so many
questions that the whole chapter between
two friends all of that but how did you
get started in the Obama administration
I it's a story you hear a lot for Obama
staffers I had never been involved in
politics before at all at all okay I
never even volunteered for a campaign
before Wow and this guy Barack Obama was
running for president and my wife and I
had just moved to California after she
was starting law school and we didn't
know anyone and Obama denounced his
candidacy and we're huge fans because
we're both my wife and I are both what
we call incog-negro which is for those
of you're unfamiliar we look we are
black no one knows that we're black and
so Korean oh yeah my mom's Korean my
dad's black my wife's half white half
black okay and we've lived these lives
where no one knows we're black like no
knows that that's our story and so we
have this kind of weird identity and
Obama also very similarly
this weird identity so we love Barack
and so when he announced and then there
was all these like Obama camp Obama
volunteer trainings and we're like [ __ ]
it we don't know anyone in this area we
were living in San Francisco and we just
went and it was like a bunch of there
are a lot of incog-negro kids like us
there's a lot of moms and there's a lot
of teachers school community of people
and we just became super volunteers and
we became we like drank the kool-aid
it's the the Church of Obama but it was
all of these kids for the first time
believing that Obama could win because
at the time Hillary Clinton was up by
like 40 points like no one said Obama
could win everyone kept telling us we
were dumb yeah we were like brocco bomb
and they're like Hillary's gonna win
like Barack Obama can't win and so we
were like [ __ ] it like we're gonna
volunteer we're gonna do everything they
tell us to do yeah and we created these
my Barack Obama accounts because there
was no Facebook it was it was MySpace
was popular at the time oh right this is
like 2007 and just Barack photos like
full emo style yeah yeah and you'd like
create your profile and we had this
little house in Silicon Valley and we
would just have these house parties
every day not every day but every week
and then the group we became the most
active volunteer group pretty much in
the country I mean it wasn't just my
wife and I but it just kept growing and
growing and growing and then when the
campaign offense eventually said staff
everyone kept saying well Brad Jenkins
is like running this thing he became
like the unofficial leader became the
unofficial leader of these like kool-aid
drinking volunteers and then when I
finally met staff they're like well who
are you
uh-huh and then I like every answer I
gave was wrong because they're like
they're like so what do you do for a
living and I was working at a hedge fund
at the time I was like I work at a hedge
fund they're like okay and like so where
did you grow up and I was like oh Jersey
I just moved here like a couple months
with their dad
it's like so you work in finance you
just moved here but you're like running
the volunteer operation anyway so but
they didn't care yeah and so Super
Tuesday which was California came and
went our little army of volunteers kept
making calls to other states and then my
childhood friend from Jersey Kyle goes
back to Jersey it all goes back to
Jersey he was a very senior staffer on
the campaign and he was in Nevada and we
were doing a lot of work together and
they had a job up and up in Chicago and
so he called me and was like hey Brad I
know you've been volunteering would you
like to come to Chicago and this is
after Obama wrapped the nomination to
work for the general election yeah and I
quit my job I was like working my wife
and I just gotten married we like moved
to California just like I guess I'm
gonna quit my job and move to Chicago so
it was very like I didn't plan for it I
think that's the other thing with the
Obama world that's very different is I
think people think I don't know that
like we got into it to work at the White
House where he got into it because we
like wanted power or whatever but like
most of the kids like me we just
believed in the guy we just really
believed in this idea and we sort of got
pulled along for the ride ya know you it
seemed like the way you write about it
that it was intuition in so many regards
and also like optimism and just
believing in a good pure cause yeah
believing in someone that had good
intentions and like hoping that things
could change and happen well the crazy
thing I mean it's so crazy to think
about now cuz I talked to younger I go
to college campuses and talk to kids now
and they're like Obama's old now like
I'm old but he ran he ran very much to
bring the country together I ran this
idea that there aren't red states or
blue states like we can come together as
a country and he had this very unique
identity where he saw both sides of
every story like she saw both sides of
white and black and
immigrant non-immigrant and and that was
my story my parents are Republicans and
so he struck a chord with me with this
idea that I was just so tired of Clinton
Bush fighting it was just like Bush
Clinton Clinton Bush and so Obama was in
a way like Bernie before Bernie was
Bernie right like this is why I tell all
the Bernie kids because he was so
aspirational when people said why do you
support Barack Obama it was like you
never heard people say like his 10-point
plan on climate change or like some
people would say his opposition to the
Iraq war but most people would say
because this is a moment this is like a
generational moment yeah and we young
people want we want to say in what our
country looks like and how our country
makes decisions and so it's so crazy
though because once he president it was
like the exact opposite happened like it
became even more divisive and crazy it's
so nuts to see how intentions get spun
so without control and it's so hard now
looking at clips of our current
president and looking back at clips from
Obama and seeing just like the complete
differentiation of like reason
compassion empathy all of these just
like basic human skills the other side
we don't get to put I was just gonna say
but we were just talking about because I
was so excited when you reach out
because you have this new book called
the swingers right yeah what's the full
logline of it full logline is 18
staffers behind-the-scenes staffer so
some senior staffers but 18 staffers
share their stories of their moment
working for the president it's very
anecdotal and it's the most someone had
to the chronicle of like White House
memoirs but it's the most diverse White
House memoir in history because all of
the people are very similarly to me
never imagined that they would work at
the White House and I think most White
House memoirs you know there's a little
bit of I was in the room I'm really
smart you know
in the back of my brain is going to end
up here totally I went to all the right
schools yeah the right thing whereas
this one is very much it's very like
impostor syndrome like every and then we
didn't share our stories with each other
you did it no we we just wrote them at
least maybe no no one shared but when
reading them it's just there's a through
line of everyone feeling such privilege
and such an honor that they're even
[ __ ] work like even that you get to
walk into the White House let alone that
you get to work at the White House and
so I think that again not to compare it
to this White House but there's this
idea of it's the people's house like we
are just honored to be there and we're
just trying to do good for people that
was really our job day to day and so
each anecdote is about that and it's
also the balance of like personal life
there are a lot of stories of you know
people going through real [ __ ] and their
lives while also simultaneously trying
to run the country which is also a
challenge I it's so insane cuz your
chapter is so much like you say it's so
it's spoken so casually about something
that is like the highest like job level
thing security wise that you could ever
like get invited to in the entire United
States and okay I want to talk about the
Affordable Care Act it's part of your
chapter it was a launch that was miss
launched a little bit and then knows
awful between two ferns like Bradley
Cooper's saved the day
Bradley Cooper speaking of a stars born
to read it's so so wonderfully like good
to read and I mean so I think everyone
was kind of shocked and amazed when
Barack Obama showed up on between two
ferns with Zach Galifianakis that was
something that was very cool yeah and
exciting so how you had a huge play
that happening how did that happen it
was yeah it was so I don't want to get
too deep into the ACA but I'll try to
because it's so like it's so interesting
to me yeah well if people want to know
more about the ACA they can read the
book so we had this this law and then it
passed and then we at the White House
had to go out there and tell people
millions of people that they now had
benefits to this law right it's not
unlike other administration's dealt with
this with like seatbelt laws which was a
big deal like everyone had to go out and
say their seatbelt laws you have to
click it or you get a ticket this whole
thing so we to do this with this White
House and the thing we had to do is
drive people to this website
healthcare.gov yet which didn't work
guys remember that which is very
embarrassing
so didn't work for two months and so but
up until that moment our office was in
charge of figuring out how do you get
how are we gonna get people to go click
on this website and sign up and we had
all these ideas but a lot of the ideas
were around people like race like people
who had communities that trusted them
right because when you work at the White
House half the country doesn't trust you
yep like half the country does not
matter what you say what you do no one
is gonna trust you you could save a
completely helpless dog and they'd be
like that dog could have helped itself
you didn't need to do that that dog
looks like a Nazi so yeah so we knew we
needed we needed help essentially so my
job was coming up with plans of how do
we work with people who have huge
networks and huge influence and so you
know the everyone said like go to glady
speaking of Bradley Cooper go to Lady
gaga or go to Pharrell or go to these
people with huge audiences which we did
but then when the website didn't work
they're so [ __ ] pissed Oh
how you described getting calls from
like Gaga and where she's Jones's PR
teams in the middle of the night while
changing your baby's diapers is nuts
and gives me anxiety by association just
reading it so please read that it's so
sad so yeah we that when we line up all
these people to get the word out didn't
work and then so we had to rejigger and
rethink what are we gonna do to
reintroduce the website at work and one
of the ideas that we had we had a number
of ideas by the way wasn't just between
two ferns but we all love between two
ferns I don't know how much of your
audience are fans at that time that was
like the biggest show that was happening
it was the most interesting thing
happening and the cool thing about it
was the format works for we're trying to
do which was it would have been awkward
for Obama to go on like a late-night
talk show to talk about like a legit
late-night talk show yeah the idea that
he would go on Zach's show the whole
show is silly and dumb and and for him
to just get made fun of for a good like
six minutes straight it was great and
like it's you don't typically get to see
that ever you don't get him and his
character that he is willing to use the
comedy as a ticket to like explain
things towards insight blows my mind
still that he's like so welcoming of
that we I mean also in full honesty like
we were desperate the other part of it
was but trusting could that could go
either way I'd go either way that's true
I mean there's huge risk there's huge
reward then the we the way that I laid
it out so senior staff was it's kind of
like the way that you guys work we knew
the numbers like every between tunes two
ferns video had millions of views so we
were essentially like look this is the
baseline and this is with like Michael
Cera and like you know these are famous
people but they're not the present
United States right so we essentially
like look regardless we're gonna get
incredible traffic people are gonna
learn about this and we trusted it I
mean how's the other thing like we
really trusted Funny or Die because we
trusted
you know they had this pedigree of Will
Ferrel Adam McKay SNL like they had this
pedigree of doing comedy for social good
yeah and you know the back-and-forth
though with Zach Galifianakis and Scott
Aukerman was so interesting because he
didn't really give a [ __ ] about the
health care all they cared about was
we're gonna make the funniest [ __ ]
video of all time like that's all they
cared about and as they should yeah and
all we cared about was getting people to
this website so there was this balance
of you know we really wanted to talk
about when I say we like our senior
staff like want to talk about
healthcare.gov in the first minute right
like we wanted to just get into it
and they're like we can't do it this
morning and the way that he's just like
what do you want to plug go ahead do
your plug and it keeps going it's not at
the beginning or end it's in the middle
it's great it's like very it feels
natural feels natural all right it feels
very organic so so yeah that but it you
know and as I write in the book there
was just there are a lot of ways I think
Mike Farah who I grace knows at Funny or
Die
he's done these like big projects before
and he's a guy who just knows how to a
good producer just knows how to like
make the project live yeah like like
you're just gonna figure out a way for
it not to die yeah and there are a
number of ways that it could have just
died because you know one I think the
back-and-forth with the creative control
we did want to see some of the jokes
beforehand so we had to sort of
negotiate that a little bit yeah and
then the timing was very quick like we
had at once with the help of Bradley
Cooper we actually got it signed off on
like wheat they had to move we have to
read a chapter to see exactly how
Bradley Cooper affected this deal and
manage this deal because it blows my
mind and I still don't know why Bradley
Cooper doesn't have social media to this
day but hey we all work in different
ways it's amazing if Bradley Cooper had
social media that
would have been five minutes never
developed it never developed yeah so
quick Bradley Cooper story Bradley came
to the White House very similar to Grace
and memory we had some much better Kemp
than Grace's memory he was uh he was
with Sookie at the time there he was
with this day and we had time to kill
before the state dinner and so we met
with Valery and we were meeting with a
lot of people we met with JJ Abrams's
that day with all these like incredibly
amazing people that day and Colbert and
all these people and we were asking
Bradley for help we're like what would
you do we're trying to get the word out
on Obamacare can you help us and he's
like I'm not on social I can't help and
we're like oh okay
he's like but you guys should do between
twofer and he just kept going on and on
he's the greatest between two ferns fit
ranks he had been on it twice and so
he's just like it's so funny
have you seen it he's like do you want
me to show it in like valerie's like do
you want me to show you is like I was
like I've seen it like I'm familiar with
what it is and so he actually called
Zach in her office which was incredible
and pitched Zach and and then he ran
around the White House telling everyone
that we should do between two ferns
grassroots promote really he was he was
like told the president you gotta do
between two ferns can't Bradley Cooper
get any better no you can't
god bless Brett okay Brad we just take a
quick break when we get back I want to
talk about midterm elections and like
why people aren't informed should be
informed etc all those light-hearted fun
things everyone looks talking about Judy
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
two deep guys are you hiring there are
job sites that send you tons of the
wrong resumes I sort through and make
you wait for the right candidates to
apply for your job but that's not smart
you know what is smart if you go to zip
recruiter calm slash grace to hire the
right person
how ironically coincidental if they're
you know supportive this episode of not
Judy is such a coincidence
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you it got powerful matching technology
which scans thousands of resumes
identifies people with the right skills
education and experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply so
you get qualified candidates fast
yeah there's no more sorting through the
wrong resumes no more waiting for the
right candidates to apply that's why zip
recruiter is rated number one by
employers in the US this rating comes
from hiring sites on trust pilot with
over 1000 reviews right now our viewers
and listeners can try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash grace that's super
Cruiser comm slash grace zip recruiter
comm slash grace zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire Wow what's up grace
I am hardly shocked that this episode is
sponsored by Squarespace yeah they are
they are our good buddy you guys know
this by now and if you're new welcome to
our Squarespace add read yeah turn your
dream into a reality with our good
buddies Squarespace we actually love
that Squarespace makes it easier than
ever for you to launch your passion
project whether you're thinking to start
a new business showcase your work
published content sell products and more
it is the tool for you with beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks
you can easily make a beautiful website
yourself Plus Squarespace is powerful
ecommerce functionality lets you sell
anything online and analytics help you
grow your site in real time everything
is optimized for mobile right out of the
box and there's nothing to patch or
upgrade ever buying domains is super
simple and you'll get the help you need
with Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support Squarespace empowers
millions of people from designers to
lawyers artists to gamers even
restaurants
gyms and filmmakers and podcasters such
as myself oh you can possibly speak from
experience about using this thing that
has sponsored our webcast yes and let me
tell you guys it's really easy to use
and you really can make a professional
looking website by yourself like I was
skeptical and then I tried it and I
didn't even need the 24/7 award-winning
customer support humble brag so turn
your great ideas into something real
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code grace G race
EE to save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain that
squarespace.com / grace offer code grace
okay we're back and okay this is an
important episode to me because I want
to talk about midterm elections I have
been a human being that has kind of
someone in his once told me that I
mister magoo my way through life which i
think is the most accurate description
of me and so I've been extremely
uninformed on our government for years
and years and we were talking a little
bit before we started this about like
why that is I have a theory that in high
school I think I was so overwhelmed by
like history history class yeah that I
just remembering dates and figures and
people and things overwhelm me so much
that I just kind of like pushed out my
brain in the art like come into my brain
yeah and so I think now as an adult like
thinking about government and politics
and being active proactive in that world
is like conditioned for me to be like no
no no just you know make your YouTube
video do that sort of thing
and I think there's a lot of people that
might feel that way because now as an
adult I feel slightly dumb and
uninformed and almost embarrassed to
like ask questions about things and I
think a lot of people are doing a really
great job to start explaining things
Billy Eichner I know you work with is
doing amazing amazing work I was like
really trying to break it down for young
people especially and so I was excited
to have you here to be able to use you
as a voice to speak to a lot of the
people that watch or listen about why
term elections are important yeah and
the basic ideas of like how people can
vote which I think still overwhelms
people so they don't do it yeah I mean I
was the same way I grew up in a house my
parents were very conservative and they
had this idea that politics and
government was just corrupt like it's
all corrupt yeah your dad doesn't trust
us anyway yeah and so and I also grew up
in Trenton where it's actually true like
all politicians and trend are corrupt
space that's there but um but no I mean
I think we grew up and in a way you're
also talk culturally that you're not
supposed to talk about politics like
there's almost this idea when you're
younger that it's not nice to talk about
politics or is not polite and then for
whatever reason once people turn 18
you're like you should vote and then
it's like well wait you told me I
shouldn't talk about yeah so there we
don't do a good job at make I agree with
you like making it cultural I think
that's the missing piece because I think
politics and government really just
comes down to people right and it comes
down to people making decisions for you
yeah and when I the class that changed
the world for me was my senior year we
had to like go to school board meetings
and we had to like go like to City
Council meeting they'd like go and watch
what it looked like yeah and it was so
sad because you'd go and there would be
no one there it'd be like six school
board members and like two people in the
audience and it's like any questions and
like the two crazy people in town that
were there or like I've got a question
and then that would be it yeah yeah and
then those six people are making the
decisions very important decisions for
thousands of students hundreds of
teachers funding decisions school
closures I mean really important
decisions and no one is there no one is
paying attention known as is invested
and so especially as a parent now it's
like I think younger people I get it
like twelve percent of young people
voted in the last midterms
well percent awful number twelve percent
because I think you're taught you know
elections every four years
right there's very minimal until now
dialogue about midterm elections
mattering and so that is I think still
confusing like I understand right
fundamentally that they matter
extraordinarily right now but I can't
say the in years past I would have had
such an understanding about it yeah and
in midterm elections I mean every
election is important for the midterm
elections actually end up becoming way
more important than presidential
elections we it is because here's the
thing most laws that you're dealing with
are at the state level right we're at
the district level and midterm elections
everything's on the ballot legislative
races state Senate races governor's
races Senate races congressional races
and the reason why I feel like it's more
important is because turnout is so low
during midterm elections so your vote
matters much more yeah right so you know
unfortunately I'm a Democrat so I can be
very open about that but Democrats get
their ass kicked every midterm election
it happened for Obama because we fall
asleep because young people are you see
that Amazon Prime now deliver service
and we can't Amazon Prime our votes so
we sort of we sort of fall asleep and
what ends up happening is the Democratic
base by and large is a voter base that
is younger and more diverse and
therefore equality right there for equal
rights for everyone equal rights does
not matter who you pray to does not
matter who you love does not matter what
you look like
we're country you come from what
language you speak you should have an
equal shot in this country you shouldn't
be discriminated against that's the
fundamental you know core of the
Democratic Party and so you know
generally younger and more diverse
people vote that way yeah the Republican
Party unfortunately you know they and
particularly this party and Trump in
particular are really questioning that
questioning whether diversity is our
strength or questioning whether who you
pray to makes you somehow different or
it's it's a very troubling time but
unfortunately older vote
who sort of view the world that way they
always vote gas in their cars to go to
the polling station I think yeah they
it's a very old school system that
that's what they're used to their issue
and the other the other reality whether
you're Republican or Democrat or
independent the reality is that 92
percent of incumbents win which means
once you get into office you're good
yeah you got pretty much a lifetime job
the only threat to that is a whole bunch
of new people voting right so when
you're in office you're kind of cool
with young people not voting you're kind
of cool with voter registration numbers
not skyrocketing and people coming out
and voting because that essentially
means you may be voted out yeah so if
once you're in it's there's not as much
of a you know it's a vicious cycle of
politicians wanting young people not to
care in a way I know sounds very
pessimistic but I mean even on the
Democratic side Joe Crowley who's beaten
by Alexandria costea Cortes he recently
just said he's like I lost because of
Millennials as if that's a bad thing
like I lost because Millennials got
fired up and voted so I think that you
know midterms matter more particularly
this election because - two big facts
one Millennials are now the largest
eligible voting bloc which is crazy
because we think that we don't have
power
we're like the sleeping giant if we
actually and if we just got up and did
some we just got up and voted the
country would fundamentally change right
and so and it doesn't matter what issue
you care about I think just the act of
going out and voting is such a big deal
and the second thing is you know the
people you know again you may have Trump
voters and who may be offended by this
but I have a lot of friends particularly
in LA who get very angry at Trump voters
and they get very angry like my parents
are Trump voters yeah my dad's black and
you voted for Trump right
so you know you can vote for who you
want to vote for Trump won because the
largest population of people on election
day were non voters that was the largest
segment of the population people Justin
vote I have yeah I have friends that
didn't vote and I shamed them for it
yeah they say they'll never ever do that
again
I hope that you know actions speak
louder than words that yeah that they
don't ever do that again
and I think it's we're seeing we're
seeing the results of the women's March
we're seeing the results of people
waking up and realizing like what the
[ __ ] did we just how do we have a
reality show post as a president who's
calling people horseface right how do
how do we let this guy calling it
tweeting it quitting it into like
permanent like internet language like
not even just saying it what off like
it's just yep we all read about history
books in the Library of Congress so yeah
so I think people have woken up and
voter turnout is up during primaries
we're seeing it like young people are
voting at much higher numbers great yeah
it's not even close to where we need it
to be I mean Taylor Swift kind of like
broke her quote/unquote silence I'm
speaking politically and I think she did
an amazing job of not just saying
vaguely go vote like instead gave very
specific details on things that matter
to her right and the reasons that she is
voting without pushing her agenda just
saying this is why I'm doing it I
encourage you to inform yourself and
then voter registration skyrocket
rocketed like crazy like the record for
vote daughter and then Trump said he
likes her music 20% less or some
[ __ ] like that yeah the nicest
insult he's ever given by the way it's
like I like her 20% less
[Music]
but but I think people like that that
appeal to that kind of like younger
generation that realize like oh these
kind of shiny happy you know celebrities
actually have opinions young not that
they're pushing a specific agenda but
they're just telling me to like figure
it out for myself is so important I'm
learning that now as a 33 year old and I
wish I had more of this kind of
information at my fingertips when I was
18 totally well we need it and I think
again not to I mean part of the reason
why we invited Grace and mamrie and
Hannah and Tyler by the way we invited
grace to the first meeting with the
president but you were you didn't come
you were like business too scared you're
too scared because I got a manager made
up an excuse I literally got the email
and I was sitting in a cabin in LA with
like my ex-boyfriend and I read it out
loud and I was like I don't get
political on my channel I'm so neuron
Tevan know what I would do
yeah I was invited I think with Hannah
and tires everywhere yeah and I passed
on it because I was just like so
overwhelmed also because I was so
uninformed about politics at that time
and I didn't even know what to do you
would have loved that meaning now
I watched Hannah's like fervor before
and after and like watch the videos and
everything and I felt like I fully
missed an opportunity and I think I was
literally the same reason I'm asking
these questions was just like sitting in
this ball of fear of not knowing what to
do with that opportunity because I felt
overwhelmed by politics at that time and
I felt like I didn't know exactly how to
use my platform to be able to speak or
you a funnel whatever I was gonna get
from that meeting into something that
made sense yeah which is why I respect
Taylor for like when she put something
out it was completely informed
completely like personal and specific
without being overwhelming and I just at
that point for myself did not know how
to like handle that kind of situation
it's a lot I mean it's a lot
particularly for you guys the way that I
view and I think I talked to you and
Chester about it like yeah this idea of
community like you guys build
communities
and that's fundamentally what in my
opinion we need in our politics right
now we all of our institutions have so
degraded like no one trusts anything
anymore right we don't trust the media
we don't trust the Democratic Party or
the Republican Party we just we don't
trust anything and I think that that was
a conversation in the room with the
president was one it was amazing because
he like knew every wall maybe he lied a
little bit but he I think he did know
cuz I Sasha and Malia I think he did
know definitely a lot of the people in
doing know and I heard that they were
like he addresses like by our name I
don't care five seconds before he walked
in that room it was enough he because
he's a dad and because his daughters
were at that age where they trusted
Hanna and they trusted Tyler right and
you he was so into the meeting and it
was so funny because so is in the
Roosevelt Room and we had like senior
staff behind him like our communication
staff yeah and it was an hour and a half
meeting and he essentially was just like
[ __ ] on what we do every day
Pew's [ __ ] on like everything we do
is so antiquated and no one cares about
press releases yeah I also heard that
hand I got a little excited and like
dominated 90% of the meeting afterwards
like yep I can totally see that
happening that she was like this is my
opportunity for all good reasons are
great I care about this I want to see
change I get to talk to a person that
has direct control of that and this
might be my only opportunity to ever do
that he [ __ ] owned a we also teed it
up to her though because we briefed him
and we had her like sui sui' I did the
seating chart we had her literally right
in front of the president I heard
everything afterwards night I did feel
like I miss out but I was still like
excited that people like us like
quote/unquote we're getting seats at the
table yeah in so many words like getting
the
privileged to be able to have these
conversations because we're still
learning our own influence and we're
still learning our own platform we're
still learning the right and wrong ways
to speak about things we care about
that's essentially in the meaning I
think at least from my perspective and I
we could Rabb lunch afterwards and we
were talk like hey Tyler
they're amazing Tyler turn a hand and
was like I think we leveled up I wish I
like recorded that greatest moment we
had lunch and they were they were so
empowered because the president all of
us were saying like cumulatively around
the room there was more power because
organizations that we work with come to
the White House every day and they're
like we have X number of people that we
can reach an X number of people that we
can activate an X Y or Z but it's not
really true I mean a lot of these
organizations they're old they're
faceless they're faceless they don't
have you know maybe people will donate a
dollar here or there but really
activating people to care about
something or to volunteer or to do
something is so very different yeah
then you know signing up on an email
list and so I mean that's what the
president everyone said they essentially
we wanted to learn from you guys and we
also wanted to figure out a way where
the issues that you guys cared about
like how can we sort of coordinate but
the biggest lesson which I think was the
empower thing was like you don't need us
like in fact it's probably better for
you not to work with the White House
because then it doesn't seem like you're
being influenced or it doesn't seem like
we're doing a brand deal so it was so
cool because I think and from the
meeting I think you know depending on
who was there because there are people
there who didn't do anything like he saw
I mean they're people they're just kinda
like this was cool but didn't become
politically active but I think that the
people who were there who removed really
have a nice you see it with Tyler and
Hannah like they stepped up in such a
huge way and they way your
later their so still empowered and still
I mean fighting for rights and people
and things that they believe in and are
speaking out about it now which is like
more important like you said than ever
to get out now and figure out like what
do you stand for what do you believe in
voting I mean I've heard the phrase like
voting is a right voting as a privilege
for so long and it never really
resonated with me until this previous
election said they didn't do it yeah I
was so I know just like hit me all of a
sudden that I'm like you're allowed to
do this thing that so many people aren't
allowed to do and that the other thing
that infuriates me too is the amount of
effort and again I'm getting a little
too deep but but there are so many
powers that be that are trying to keep
you from voting yeah they don't want you
to vote they're gonna they're making as
hard as possible for you to vote oh it's
so I've done absentee ballot for ever
cuz I'm from Jersey and for the very
first time in the previous election a
couple months ago I went to an actual
polling place it was the first time I'm
33 years old first time I show this
great person I was so excited to get my
goddamn stick and so it's like you have
to do I had a like a full shoot day and
I think the polling place closes an hour
go just go even though you're scared you
don't know how it works yeah etc and
then I like went upside right like
logged in whatever that's my internet
speak for signed in to vote and then
they gave me my ballot and I went to
this incredibly complicated machine it
was like I learned your fellow New
Jerseyan so you didn't have to pump your
own gas growing up the first time I
learned to pump my own gas so I felt
like I was learning to pump my own gas
for the first time again I was so
embarrassed that I could not figure out
how this machine worked but I still like
sat there was like you're going to
figure this out and I was like why did
they make this so incredibly complicated
it's not me to be so complicated yeah
I'm like put a polling station at a
7-eleven make it available through
Twitter and you get so many Millennials
voting it'll be crazy
it should be automatic voter registrar
doing it now where you turn 18 you
should be
automatically registered to vote it's
ridiculous I checked my voter
registration a month ago because I saw
everyone going nuts about it online
being like just check and I was like
guess I'll check
I wasn't registered yeah I juve or was
it no I have no I literally had voted
like a few weeks prior when I wasn't
registered so I went on like vote gov or
vote or whatever it was registered and I
had to re register - two seconds but I
was so thankful that I actually checked
the the problem is I think one I think
we have to start talking about community
and citizenship and civics earlier yeah
I think and I think you're right I think
we need to use arts to do it and I think
that the cool thing about Taylor Swift
and John Legend and all these artists is
they're doing it in a way to your point
like they're not telling you who to vote
for they're just expressing who they
care about and like what matters to them
and it makes younger people start to
think Oh what matters to me yeah because
a lot of these decisions the other the
other rant I'll have is you know Trump
has already put two Supreme Court
justices on the Supreme Court in two
years my kids are gonna have these guys
right I mean this is that these
decisions there are a lot bigger than
just four years these are like life long
decisions and so the quicker that we can
start getting younger people
understanding that that like climate
change is a [ __ ] threat like we can't
wait another four years to do [ __ ] but
really I'm like 12 years left exactly so
I think that that's I think that's the
big thing is is just making it feel like
one that although it's complicated you
can figure it out and state-by-state so
you know in a state like Wisconsin you
can actually register and vote on the
same day like literally like you can you
don't you have to there's no rotation
deadlines you can just go register and
vote the full drive that's great and in
states like Colorado it's something like
90% of the state does vote by now there
aren't even polling locations it's just
you vote by mail so there are states
where we can make it easy if we want to
yeah again I think it just comes down to
unfortunately powers-that-be Republicans
and Democrat
it's there is a lot of there's a lot of
power in not changing not changing these
laws and so if we elect if younger
people this cycle get in there get fired
up go vote we can make this [ __ ] a lot
easier it should be as easy as voting
online like it should be also the amount
of things this is what I to anyone well
November 6 are the midterm elections
just to put this out there because this
episode will come out before then yes
thank you for that
of course no that's why this is so
important so make sure you get out on
November 6 and vote and I will not take
that you don't know how to do it as a
response because the amount of things
that we Google how to do what is this
what or what does this mean on a daily
basis that you can't Google how do I
vote in my midterm elections in the
state of blah blah blah
like look through your google search
history and all the insane mundane [ __ ]
they've googled previously and actually
look up something that affects you and
the world at large on that fired up
quick break and when we get back thank
God we're gonna talk about [ __ ] stories
[Music]
it's brought you by fabfitfun if you
love discovering new products if you're
always on the hunt for the next best
thing then you've got to try fabfitfun
they are a seasonal subscription box
with full size fashion beauty home
fitness and wellness products delivered
four times a year for just $49.99 a box
it's great for discovering new brands
and products you can actually use
because everything is full-size no more
paying for samples fabfitfun is a
fantastic value many products individual
value is more than the entire cost of
the whole box fabfitfun is a great gift
to get yourself and makes a great gift
for a loved one and i can say with full
and utmost confidence that this box is
fantastic like I said it's actual
full-size samples of products that you
might not have discovered on your own
so why not give it a try sign up for
fabfitfun today fabfitfun boxes are
amazing and always sell out so use my
code grace your AC to get $10 off your
first box go to fabfitfun dot-com to
sign up and start getting the bucks for
a life well-lived use promo code grace
for $10 off your first box that's over
$200 for 39.99 fabfitfun comm use code
grace get $10 off your first fabfitfun
box support for today's show comes from
crave k ra ve it is a jerky company and
they've supported us before and I'm so
thankful yeah and they make delicious
jerky made with tender gourmet cuts of
meat and elevated yet simple ingredients
crave jerky is a great source of protein
that's low in fat gluten free contains
all natural ingredients and is delicious
it truly is they have a range of flavors
that is as you could put it bold and
imaginative from sweet and tangy to
savory and spicy I like the sweet
Chipotle beef but honestly this is I'm a
chip girl my whole life and this is
basically just like meat chips that you
can in the pantry it's really great so
honestly you really can't go wrong with
any of the flavors they've got a bunch
of really cool ones including lemon
garlic Turkey and garlic chili pepper
beef they sound crazy but give them a
try because you would be truly delighted
my favorite is the chili lime beef but
anyway if you guys want to try it out
you can any of their bold and tender
flavors such as chili lime beef or black
cherry barbecue pork for instance by
going to crave jerky calm that's crave
with a K and you'll get 20% off when you
use the offer code grace that's crave
jerky calm or offer girl grace okay Brad
we're back and back just a little levity
here we're gonna ask you two to the two
questions I ask every single guest here
on the podcast and the first is who
alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti at there's so many
options these days most politically
minded guests and usually all of our
comedy guests go political here in this
question they don't feel the need to be
political in this world that's the thing
I've been talking
you know I I was gonna say Kanye but I
actually feel bad for Connie I don't
know if you guys have been talking about
Kanye but I have actually thinking about
it almost feel bad for him at this point
I read a very very Hank green retweeted
this BuzzFeed article that I thought was
very articulate about why it makes sense
that Kanye supports Donald Trump go
through my Twitter if you guys want to
go back in there and see that article
it's on BuzzFeed it was really
fascinating and just kind of brought
more of a full picture to what Trump
represents these kind of outsiders that
care about there have always been
outsiders and consider themselves like
outside like the normal realm of what
people support and so they all come
together
he's like the ultimate yeah but I also
think you would you know that would be
his next music video
spaghetti show I'm gonna go with I'm
gonna go with Donald Trump jr. oh and
even if you like Trump I mean you can't
like Donald Trump he's just like he's
mean he's rude he's aggressive he's just
like full of himself and he's it's just
why consequences this entire life yeah
same said for his father okay so other
question I ask every guest on the
podcast is to tell us your worst pants
shooting story or close call you can
only use three words or three small
phrases or some combo so - college
jogging front lawn well I am a fan of
not 2d I've heard many episodes and I'm
always so fascinated by people who don't
have a story thank you thank you I feel
like they're either lying or I guess
they do really well I just wanna say
they eat well or something train so mine
is I have a number but the one that's
the least embarrassing is India okay how
do I fascinated you got
India escaping a cab okay city street
yeah believe it that it was yeah if
anyone is that very tribal I was with
and I escaping a cab with your boss I
was with Mike fair at the time oh my god
he escaping a cab because it was so
before we went i spoke to friends who'd
like traveled ice back not to name drop
but Cowpens yeah shout to cow because he
had travel with the president India and
Mike and I were going for the State
Department cultural mission and cow was
like drink bottled water right and don't
eat street food essentially because
you're because the everything is just
cooked differently the water is not that
sanitary and i thought i did that but i
thought mike and i did that the whole
time but mike got back and he literally
was out for like two weeks like he
couldn't even go to the Emmys I think
why Emmy Award yeah Mike like was
destroyed and for me I was fine the
whole time as we're going to the airport
like it just hit me like cold sweats
know it's coming call I told our top cab
driver pull over
yeah and you know it was international
politics
some might say okay questions or
Internet questions at large so I want to
know what is your advice for someone who
wants to work in government and politics
like what's the main I know yeah you
have a full TED talk online
that's very cool that gives some like
kind of just like it seems like life
advice but I think some of the most
might apply to this like what's your
biggest kind of lesson for someone that
was involved it's so easy is the other
thing I think that what I would
recommend depending on where you live
how old you are it's look up a candidate
well it's hard now it's like right
before Election Day but traditionally
speaking there's elections every year
those elections for school board there's
elections for aldermen City Council
someone is running for office yeah look
who's running for office in your area
and go to their website and volunteer
just go to their campaign office
you will be surprised you will end up
running the campaign by the end yeah
became the unofficial leader of the San
Francisco Obama group also I heard Tyler
Oakley mention this on his podcast a
couple weeks ago that I thought was a
really interesting way if there are
organizations that you believe in they
usually support or back certain
political candidates and so you can
research like through that way and get a
kind of knowledge about someone that you
might not not have known about before
yeah I think the coolest thing you'll
find is not to sound cheesy or sappy is
if you get involved it's incredible how
much power you can have because very few
people particularly younger people
during the Obama campaign the high
school students for Barack Obama all
ended up working at the White House they
literally all because they were they saw
it all at such a young age and they saw
how all the sausage was made that by the
time they like went to college they were
[ __ ] like Scott they were like eh D's
on how to how campaigns are run you
can't learn about that in school you
have to be involved in the actual like
grassroots of it all it does not require
and grace you're very self-deprecating
but you are spilling it you're so smart
but people but politics makes people
think that they're dumb you only mean
like they make it feel like you need to
know everything about tax policy or earn
income tax credits or you need to know
about you know I don't know
non-discretionary defense budgets when
in reality you don't need to know any of
those things every single word you just
said makes my inner like dumb child
that's insecure about framing smart go
John I avoid avoid avoid right instead
of just allowing yourself I think the
cool thing too which is what I found
when I first started youtube is the
community that it builds mmm that you
said when you were in San Francisco with
your wife that like you found a
like-minded group of people that were
all kind of rooting for the same thing
and that in itself is hugely powerful it
became more Obama almost became like an
avatar like it yeah we we really just
liked hanging out with each other and
the journey that we were building
so yeah it's not hard go find a campaign
and especially if it's before Election
Day oh this is a great plug yeah this is
coming out before Election Day there are
so many campaigns that you can go and
volunteer for and there's a number of
organizations that are doing all these
create get-out-the-vote efforts the one
that i am a part of is called glam up
the midterms @billyeichner i saw that
amazing yes and we're going all over the
country we're going this weekend we're
going to Vegas and Detroit and you can
only get into the show if you register
the votes right with literally bribing
we literally private but no I mean we're
we're making it we're making free fun
shows but you have to commit to the
register to vote to attend and so so
yeah come to a glam up the midterms
event there's a lot and it's not just us
a lot of campaigns are doing this so
that's awesome okay someone to know did
you ever ask weird questions to Obama I
know that you had the opportunity to
brief him on all of these stats post the
between two ferns video which must have
been extraordinarily overwhelming to say
that his comedy video has done well for
the United States I know and I went in
there thinking this was gonna be like my
Shakespearean soliloquy me like this is
my like West Wing moment like the
cameras gonna zoom in and it's gonna be
like and he was just like cool you know
like it's like the least important thing
he did like all year I was like this is
my moment I'm trying to think we it was
kind of fun we briefed we did a lot of
meetings with artists and we briefed we
had Adam Scott I'm huge Adam Scott yeah
and I've gotten to know Adam through
funnier died and his wife Naomi and
they're so cool and Adam they had this
idea of doing a stepbrothers sketch for
for healthcare.gov haha and it's it's
still on Funny or Die it's really really
funny so we like put it in the memo and
I remember briefing the president he's
like oh love stepbrothers
[Laughter]
president of all times one of my
questions for you it was like when you
were in the White House do you have a
stand out like most fever dream moment I
know that like shooting between your
insane and intense but was there any
other I mean it just must be insane what
you see on a yeah it's a pens I mean
there were it like when working at the
White House is just crazy because every
day every day you're meeting someone
it's their greatest day of their life
yeah like we a lot of our job was just
lifting people up and telling their
story and so whether it's like a teacher
or a nurse or so every day you're crying
cuz it's someone come you like to come
to the White House like we're honoring
them and and so every one of those
moments is so amazing because
particularly people I would say
particularly people who are older like
in their 70s or 80s and would have never
imagined to be at the White House
especially I would say communities that
like never get invited to the White
House you know like African American
Korean Sikhs Muslims it was such a
special time we we also sort of I think
we even knew that it was like we're
probably not going to get this chance
again so so that was cool and then of
course there's like the stories of like
crazy celebrities and you're just like
how like Rihanna like we hung out with
Rihanna for like 12 hours for some
reason yeah she's like 15 people in her
entourage is very bizarre I mean what a
great
we hung out with Rihanna for 12 hours
for some reason that's so funny yeah I
saw the Cleveland Browns documentary
about like the 85 team Chicago Bears
yeah sorry I'm getting the ESPN
documentary series mixed up but yeah
that they got invited by Obama I watched
better on a plane and there's a
documentary yeah yeah that he invited
them no I met them all yeah it was
incredible there's a documentary out
about it and it's like they were so
overwhelmed with joy to be invited and
it was just like ah like crying about
these men that yeah have been through
10,000 basic car accidents in their
athletic career it's great and they
didn't get invited because oars pulled
down because there's a challenger
spacecraft tragedy yeah and then they
just never rescheduled it yeah and so
it's insane to see like how much it
meant to them and a lot of them talking
about like got invited with an African
American president how much more
meaningful it was been totally oh it was
just so great okay
here's a very specific someone tweeted a
very New Jersey question yes Jersey
Taylor ham or pork roll a pork roll how
about you cuz you grew up in North
Jersey
Craster's near Philadelphia so for you
it's Taylor
no it's pork but also scrapple scrapple
yeah my grandfather made a scrapple all
the time and he lived by the Jersey
Shore my whole life so that's mine Jack
what's yours oh I love scrapple sir
apples yeah yeah pork roll roll Taylor
hammer the North Jersey people yes
oh my wife's family are all North Jersey
people let's say they're all they're the
worst yeah they're Taylor here how do
you describe the difference between the
two Taylor ham and pork roll difference
between the food items Taylor ham and
pork roll I don't think there is a
difference I think it's just the way you
call it okay just what we call it for
people that don't know it's essentially
spam right just fried spam like it's
just in a cast-iron skillet cook it up
basically it just absorbs your full
hangover that's what does Apple does
that too no that's what I mean all of
these just meat scraps
that's like soak up all of the sin you
put in your body the nice someone's you
know ever invite someone to the White
House that wasn't allowed in even
allowed to say that that's a really
that's an interesting question well I
know that you talk a lot about like the
security measures
the White House obviously are very very
in-depth and the system that they have
doesn't seem like super efficient all
the time so yeah I can imagine that
there might have been some there has
been I mean there it's both there are
some people that either send in their
information incorrectly or not at all
right and what ends up happening is
especially for big events they then have
to get reprocessed and so sometimes I
can take a really long time right
because it's a very quick for my
understanding very quick background
check to make sure that there are no
arrests out for warrant you know
warrants out for arrest excuse me or I
don't know like criminal conviction and
he's they do a random assortment of
checks and so we have had people come
for like Christmas party it's like it's
the worst like Christmas parties like
big events they're like in their gowns
can't get into the White House yeah so
that sucks but no we have had people who
we just couldn't let in because like
they're not allowed yeah that's happened
a number of times I mean I think I have
a tighter security system at my house
okay someone tweeted about YouTube
networking last night it was also
terrible so okay this is the last
question ask if he knows how we can get
Obama back no but I think okay I'm gonna
kind of answer this for you a little bit
I think the best way we can get the
Obama feelings back is by going out and
voting like not to like just make this
well I am making this a very heavy hands
episode about midterm elections and your
right to vote and utilizing that I think
we all feel the pain of a very wonderful
sweet human that was in office that you
know you don't know what you got til
it's gone yeah and now I think more than
ever you have to start activating
yourselves to make the necessary moves
that you can get someone like Obama back
and get someone that you believe in that
registers with your values or you can
run
oh yeah that is the the coolest thing
about all this I mean I'm like I'm sort
of The Annoying
I'm very optimistic about everything and
people just so annoying
it's very annoying to be optimistic
especially in this day and age where
people are so angry I'm like it's gonna
be okay they're like [ __ ] you man King
Miss King but um no like there's record
number of people running for office
particularly women it's like a record
number of women running for office and I
don't mean like a 100% increase like
400% increase in women running for
office at all levels like local office
federal office so I think I mean what
ended up happening was people were like
how the hell is that guy president they
start thinking about their own lives
like my sister-in-law is running and she
just won my sister was a doctor she
lives in Philly and she ran for office
local office in Philly and she won she
was just like [ __ ] I'm a doctor I know
what my patients need in terms of policy
and healthcare policy I'm gonna run for
office
that's incredible shot out to Rio pal
and her winning in Philly yeah but yeah
I think running for office and I think
that there are two Grace's point there
are incredible candidates out there so
we don't need a name drop them here but
like there's another borracho but
there's the thing about Barack Obama is
when he ran at the time everyone was
like we need someone new we need someone
fresh and then this guy just came out of
nowhere and I think that that will
eventually happen I think we will have
someone someone like a beta or orc
I didn't want to say it but you said it
for me thank you like beta or cory
booker our Jersey I love me some cory
booker yeah cory booker i think there
are people do your research and put
yourselves and the things that matter
most to you Brad this was such a
wonderful episode thank you so much for
me thanks for having thanks for going a
little deeper no I trajectory of not too
deep and I'm very excited about it but
you get what every guest gets for making
time oh my god being on the podcast is a
very I'm so excited actually it's a
personalized fortune cookie just for you
don't recommend eating it
[Laughter]
instead of live in business your India
story I don't think it'll cause that
much damage my fortune says you're
supposed to get an Emmy for between two
ferns but they're so heavy and it fell
when an intern was bringing it to the
stage so they just acted like you didn't
get one we're sorry yeah on behalf of
the Emmys we'll take the apology this is
really funny though because every
staffer gets an oval office photo uh-huh
when they leave yeah and so you get to
bring your family so I got to bring my
wife or my kids and we were with the
president we're taking photos and he
like loved the kids but the entire time
he just want to know where his Emmy was
he didn't get one he doesn't he's not a
producer so he doesn't get one and so he
kept being like so uh I'm gonna get one
right and I like I was like laughing and
I'm like yeah I figured like we'll get
you an honorary one and then like we
kept talking about the kids again he's
like yeah so we're gonna get that happy
for me right we actually reached out to
the Emmy Awards and they didn't give him
one I don't know what the rules are but
they're just they stuck to the rules and
they gave the president Wow Emmy Award I
mean I get get the vote out next time
Barack Obama Brad where can people buy
the book where can they see everything
that you're up to at Funny or Die and
they don't know Wes wingers com swegen
get the book or any I guess are there
bookstores still come back just cooling
stations so yeah it's really funny it's
really great thank you so much for for
having me on to talk about the book it's
super fun it's a really very fascinating
read and I mean I read your chapter
which was so like I said very
entertaining and unusual something you
wouldn't expect Furby here yeah very
bizarre but very cool so I highly
encourage everyone to see that and then
Funny or Die your folks are unaware
we're doing a bunch of cool stuff we're
doing a campaign with Sikhs which are a
community
that is the victim of the the most hate
crimes in the country because they wear
turban
yeah and seek members are there confused
with Muslims yeah they're not Muslim do
people think that they're Muslim okay
and unfortunately we have a president
who's ostracized Muslims in this country
and so hate crimes have increased and so
we're doing a big campaign with those
guys we're working with Google actually
I'm mostly here to try and get you to do
a campaign with Funny or Die trying to
get a creator Funny or Die campaign
going on and yeah and claim up the
midterms clam up the midterms calm
awesome so yeah and then yeah and then
on it at Brad Jenkins all social media
platforms media platforms yeah guys
please one go check out all those
wonderful things go out and vote it's
fun it's fun make it fun for yourself or
something I'll say about voting uh-huh
the Instagram photo of the I voted
sticker is [ __ ] money so good thank
you so many likes for me you can't fake
that
you can't take someone else's stick
please don't please do it Brad thank you
so much again for making time for us and
we'll see you guys next time another
episode of not too deep goodbye too deep
toady toady
not too deep is a production of grace
Helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack ferry producer and
editor Melissa de mons writing by Diane
Kang post production sound by Chris
Henry and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]